let's let's not gas it to the next level
okay so it was
it was a little bit of something spice
so they oversold it yeah they went
they could have took the atomic thing
off and took fire off and just put ball
with a little bit of spice and it would
have been
[Music]
[Applause]
ham Craig David and I'm here to do snack
Wars UK versus the US for lag Bible
vibes
Okay so
McDonald's fries yeah with a few
different chili dips and a barbecue dip
and yeah good stuff and the kind of the
kind of chips that you would get from
local chippy exactly you know what I
mean you need a little extra that salt
and some vinegar on the back yes let me
just
that's tasting a little bit wonky I'm
not gonna lie only because it's like
it's not hot not quick not crispy
and it's been left out for time that way
but
it's exactly the same with that does
and see this is where this goes this
goes a little left both for both of them
these are the kind of french fries that
you'd find down the side of the of the
car yeah a week later after we've had
the McDonald's here yeah that's
literally a hot taste so when I used to
work in McDonald's did you
I used to be like I don't know what we
do well they put me at the back they
didn't let me be at the front to touch
you serve me which was actually a good
thing because I know my mates would just
come and say like breaking this song out
of the bag or something but I just saw
everyone out but because you know those
Monopoly kind of like little tickets
they gave yeah yeah yeah where you could
win a win a Big Mac win a fight
they had to go some that's exactly it
the whole thing yeah
I was in the back and all that there was
a mound of those tickets at the back so
obviously you've got the Robin Hood
thing right you've got to redistribute
that back into the main redistro it back
in
on this one
I'm gonna go with the McDonald's fries
okay only on the basis that I think if I
did add some dips and do stuff so I
could it would make all this taste a lot
better but yeah it's something when you
have those
lukewarm it's like unicorns like cold
they're rank fine so note to ourselves
note yourself
um if you're doing hot food this is
always a good to kind of present it hot
yeah cool love it
try for this sort of like um digressing
stories they've got nothing to do anyway
and it's like great story great but
nobody cares um but can we get back to
the
Okay so
it looks as if we have love hearts yep I
like like what I love hearts I just
thought I love that I love the sentiment
I love hearts I think it's I think
they're cool that's why again they've
split the test of time and this atomic
fireball thing I have zero I have no
idea what this is about okay okay let's
try it
okay
so it's
it's like a
start to spice up a little bit
it's still on the back it says like get
in touch yeah
it's not it's not like a get in touch
tell you how it went kind of it's just
like get in touch there and then 9-1-1
you know I felt okay so let's let's not
sit to the next level okay so it was
it was a little bit of sun spice it
wasn't like my egg was coming off like
whoa so it's it's
you can handle it yeah so they oversold
it yeah they went
they could have took the atomic thing
off and took fire off and just put ball
candy with a little bit of spice and it
would have been yeah I'm kind of a big
fan of the love heart thing anyway I
think it's I like the sort of cuteness
of it yeah never know what you're gonna
expect exactly you have that in a little
bowl like in your house I'm gonna take
one of those and oh look I've got the
one that says love it
well you get the one that's all mangled
up
okay let's not forget that I want to say
let's go to
[ __ ]
they're wholesome it's from the heart
does what it says on the tin yeah
yeah so I'm out in your mouth situation
but sweet friendly friendly a hug warm
hug nice whereas the fireball
just there and I didn't live up so I'd
say in this little situation
I could say love hearts all day long no
that's UK right yeah UK
oh yeah yeah okay so
we've got the
the Doritos Spicy Sweet Chili flavor
and you just got your standard hula
hoops which I have to say
does seem like there's been some
decrease in size 100 I can feel inside
that though Loops have gone a little bit
smaller and the packet is
he's got a lot smaller so anyway uh let
me try a little
hmm I've got to say that is again
wholesome it's wholesome but it's small
yeah that's the only thing that's
probably here because I can remember
having hula hoop back in the day you
know you put them on the finger I did
the whole thing it was a whole moment I
can't even get them on my feet yeah
it's like it's this well that's not it's
not you know what I mean
it's almost like those things you've got
a memory of how it was and then you
almost don't want to yeah your hands
just got bigger maybe okay well
I'll put it like that I mean something
behind that no no you're only four years
ago
okay
I've got a photo tasty though
oh man the taste of it is intense it's
flavoursome yeah but there's always a
bit of an aftertaste with Doritos that
I'm not a massive fan of I don't know
what it is the texture of the actual
crisp itself so in this one the flavor's
amazing obviously not gonna be a flavor
because it's original
but just because they're hula hoops and
I love hula hoops from back in the day
I'm gonna go with the hula hoops
I have a feeling without even spinning
this around this is either sunki oh
the only the only time okay this is this
is uh well this is ribena nicely yeah
again the car is
like everything's just gone like I know
it used to be wider yeah yeah yeah and
more rectangle it's gonna it is it's
gone a bit more tall and slim but okay
we'll check that one out and this one's
Kool-Aid yeah
now the only time I ever hear cool
ladies like when someone says oh you've
been drinking what you're doing must be
drinking another Kool-Aid yeah which
usually sort of a reference to you're
talking nonsense or you're in your head
and you're like you must be you must
have been drinking cool lately right
right
um
yeah
I feel like this is kind of where the
problems begin
because it's like one uh it it tastes
like concentrate of the watermelon it's
trying to be
um it says it
proud with chest artificially flavored
it's not even like I'm doing it cut
artificially flavored this is what I'm
about this is this is okay so you know
what you're getting on the thing there's
Zero nutrition on the back here is there
literally nothing nothing on the back
here that's I think the panel says
everything yeah which is hence why at
the topic I said about oh you've been
drinking cool you've been drinking the
Kool-Aid right foreign
no artificial colors or flavors yeah
over no nutritional value
you know you're getting okay
UK UK for this game the UK was
[Applause]
we get it right we do we understand the
assignment
Oh my days
Oh my days
please look at that
that looks like
what comes out of my dog's bottom oh
oh my God